This
[music] Yeah
yeah
I'm glad I was worried about
what happened
Konoe, it's not the room used by the parasite on the 13th stage in front of me
n
132th place
I'm standing before we are called here  Of course
, there must have been a stage to protect this year, so
why not
? Well,
it was wiped out,
so I
couldn't go back.
[Music]
We ca
n't survive without knowing each other more
[Music]  ]
Let's make up for
everyone I apologize for that,
I won't look at you with strange eyes anymore, so I can't
do it. I don't want Miku to be too cute.
Ah,
the mold that was placed by the window The
flower that was stabbed there was a lilac flower.
I don't know how the parasites of the previous 13 stages who lived in that room were decorating it
now.  But
we later decorated a new lilac flower there again.
Lilac's flower language
It's a friendship memory
and an umbrella